hello there a very very big thank you
for having agreed to join our have had
to equip ourselves with work therefore organized by
african people's action lab
in collaboration therefore with the members
of oca copé must therefore the collective of
Congolese associations for
Zeeland landais and
dante asked because we would like
we have seen that in all this debate on
the question of the end memory of
colonial memories of how
we can tackle the injustices of
colonization the colonial crimes at we have
a constantly needs  to refer
to the archives that we need hungry
that's an element to which the device
of archiving them time but denies
central and therefore suddenly that one is
not a historian one is not that one is not  is
not familiar with the archives
there are plenty of questions we ask
ourselves is therefore suddenly have to ask for you to enlighten us in the
meander of the archives you who is a
historian and who here is who has worked
who works in  fine
who worked who still work on the archives
and the colonial archives in
belgium of which perhaps before we
start with a whole series of
questions is what just you can
tell us in a few poor times
your journey
thank you hello  and thank you very much for
this invitation so indeed I
am I am a historian trained in
history contemporary history is in
fact my research focuses more
particularly on the history of
justice and the history of rwanda but
also more recently of burundi and
eastern congo  my specialty is
court records which are in
fact documents which historians,
since we were talking about just now, are
extremely fond of because these
records offer a whole series of
perspectives and so that's
one of the questions that animated but
research is also to try to see
precisely what can be done
with these archives so it is I hope the
queue there are  points of junction
with the debates which occupies your your
seminar and your projects
yeah eh
great
in any case here we are delighted one to have
you and as and as stupidity
is there at the end of May the questions which
grind us in quotation marks it  is to
know if we want
if we want to understand
the crimes committed during
colonization to what extent the
path of the archives is a
child is an appropriate path to
what extent
it is possible to go through it
what do we have  finally what is
to the extent it is expensive ah
what does that imply as as
as as story in fact when to which we
have access to what extent or to its
partials is that already here you can
tell us  start a little bit
with this first big question 1
is this is this is this
a way to understand the issues 6
of colonization
the first element ceased to remind us that
the archives which are therefore documents
which have been produced or  by
public institutions or by
private institutions see
individuals companies religious congregations
these archives and which moreover will be
found on several media it can
be written archives it can
be iconographic documents
here is a whole series of documents
maps
these archives are the raw material
of historians
its has oral archives so of course I
do not exclude oral history
from that and what does this raw
material allow you to do well it
allows you
to observe the past  and this observation
of the past of course they go through
a whole series of questions when
we are faced with a document which has been
produced and which has been preserved since
it is perhaps a question to which
we can come back obviously it is which
are the documents that finally reach us
today from this period
of colonization and when we are
faced with this archive we pose a
series of questions or link with a
series of questions
the objective
of this archive and its
use will be to be able to contribute to answering
with a certain point of view what
had several sub-questions in this
first in this first question
it is to  to say that the archipelago is therefore
produced by an archive producer
who describes in a certain way the
reality of that time but of course
it is a point of view and therefore the
whole issue when using
c archives  is to be aware of this point of view
to deconstruct it to question it and
to confront it with other points of view
that we call the crossing of sources
therefore a single archive will not
give us direct access to the past as
that he was at that time
he will give us access to a vision of
this past which at the time and the present at
that time and therefore to address
these questions there whether it is the
historians but that said we must not
exclude all other sciences
social and human sciences and
political sciences jurists anthropologists who
also use archives but
therefore historians do what is called
historical criticism and historical criticism
is a whole series of two
methods tools of questioning which
allow to put  in context this
archive and to try to question it as
well as possible so to answer the
question do
the archives allow us to
document or understand to question
the injustices of the colonial past to
take up the question you asked
it  is certainly an essential
obviously in which we can find
a number of answers because
it is this raw material that
gives us access to those to happen
now I was saying everything also depends
on what reaches us the archived milk
produced at  a moment and then it will
be or not to keep
this conservation it will depend on
decisions and to the intellectuals
is what this  he archive has a
historical value which allows us to
preserve it it will also of course depend
on the material conditions of
conservation and transmission with we
ddr figures which can be degraded
which can be lost which can be
destroyed we have had floods
recently is even  in belgium it had
an impact on a certain number
of archives which suffered that they
could be destroyed at that time so there
are voluntary and
involuntary causes of course of destruction
of its archives
therefore to these public and private
reach us in a way
I would say sometimes sometimes sometimes partial and
if now we come back to the
specific question of the colonial archives we
are faced with yet another question which
is that these are archives that
were produced in multiple places
spoke of the congo of  burundi of rwanda these
are three geographical spaces which have
their own history which have therefore
produced their own archives their
archives they o  were produced in
africa but also in belgium so we
have funds that are split between the
two and at the end of the 50s in fact
in 1960 these archives were
partially repatriated to belgium
which means that we actually
have  documents which remained on the spot
and we have documents which were which
were repatriated I think that we estimate
today more or less at 10 km the
so-called African archives called colonial
fall bears several names which are which
are kept which are  preserved in
belgium but therefore documents have
remained on the spot some are still
preserved today others have
unfortunately disappeared have been
destroyed over time over time so these
colonial or african archives finally
here we will see what terms we keep here
they still have a particularity
is that it is part of a kind
of triptych between memory, justice
and history is clearly the
question you are asking is the  question of
demobilization in fact of its archives
and by justice we saw it with with the
mixed-race trial in Belgium and by
memory we see it by
collectives because we call
civil society and of course
by history  because historians have
been working on
its wings for years on its archives and it is true that
today we see that there is an
extremely strong demand for history
and that the discourse on  history
it is carried by many actors
including non-historians and it is very
good moreover as it is therefore
fair to me to say that yes the archives
are fundamental but of course it is
not the only source of  the information that
allows us to observe do without
interrogating it to understand it
what to do but trains to go
a little bit
further in the questions that finally
in the elements you approach you
describe a situation in which
the archives finds itself  on in
several geog spaces
the archives at are both klein
there was a whole process of sorting between
quotation marks between at
between the moment when the document has effect
and contains certain points of view the
document is archived the document it is
decided whether or not to keep it and all
the vagaries that can
[ __ ] that can become so later
and so suddenly I say to myself in a
in all in this whole process where
we have partial and partial views
here what
is finally what is  we what do we have
what we learn quotation marks on
out of
20 is what is seen what emerges
on the way in which these archives were
finally on the stories that emerges it is
still  have you been processed or
are we
still examining them and
so we can't say when we
can say
it's impossible to make an
inventory of the  injustices of
colonization from skiing of what has
been treated until now
so there are several  things would say the
first point is that this question
of points of view and what can be
taken from an archive is a fundamental question
for historians okay here I am speaking from
my point of view it is this point  of view
where I can talk and it's true that
the first question we ask ourselves and I
'm going to take the example of
court records because it's the one I
know best and where I can
give you examples  concrete when we
are faced with a legal file
we said ok in what context
this file was produced what are
the elements that I need to
understand what is happening it's not
only the context it's  is also to
understand what is the language of the one
who produced the file at the time who
are the actors that she architectures it
in this case in this case of
justice as it works and with
that once I  am facing my
file what do I find in this
file and the archives  The judiciaries are
a good example for asking this
question of injustices and also of the
way in which, in this case, the
Congolese, because this is the example
I have in mind, interact with the
system of justice which is  in fact,
colonial justice
is
what we typically find in a
legal file these are
testimonies these are confrontations
of points of view and it is the question
of establishing the facts and therefore it is
obviously a field which is
extremely interesting to observe the
question of violence to observe the
question of the interactions
between the colonized and the
colonial authorities to understand the way in which
the law is constructed and therefore which is
also of course a form of violence
in the sense that the law is  the knowledge
does not apply in the same way
to the white Congolese if we want to take
this example there in a colonial context we have
specific offenses which are
defined in a specific way  with
specific penalties so we really have an
asymmetrical system which in fact
shows through in its archives in its
judicial archives
so that's one thing it's all this
legal framework which therefore allows us to
question to question that and then
to  another aspect and which there is
transversal I would say to all the
judicial archives it is the question
of testimony is obviously the question
of testimony the historian says to himself ok there
I will have access to the voice of the
actors and the voice of the actors c  It is
also the voice of the victims or the voice
of the people who are who are who are
convicted or who are being prosecuted
accused
and obviously it is extremely exhilarating
because we say to ourselves that there we have this
capacity for direct observation to
in fact to take up an
expression of a historian marc bloch who
starts from this historical observation
by saying to the historian he will never be an
anthropologist who will not be able to go and do
his field so obviously  we can
qualify that because today it
is the case
but therefore all that can be done is
this historical observation via the
documents and therefore we are grayed out we say to
ourselves well yes the testimony there I  I have access
to the person channel but obviously
when we talk about
legal testimony even of art figures produced
by other types of
public or state institutions this channel it
is filtered it is filtered in
different ways first of all it is
transcribed in this case we are talking about a
written document which transcribed in
which language the person is
speaking it is unlikely that this
person would speak French at
the time but today this tale is
a  transcription in French
how was his remarks
summarized interpret is it
consistent with what was said then
some of the questions are a bit of a target to be
resolved obviously for the historian
today but the fact  to take them
into account and to try  having precisely to
look for the smallest very small
detail in fact of these testimonies an
information allows all the same to
circumvent all the biases that all
archives contain moreover it is not
specific to colonial or
African archives and therefore to be able to try to
find  this original way in any
case to put it also I would say in
resonance with other types of archives
you can think of
oral history campaigns also for
more recent periods which can put that in
perspective and that is to say  things
that are finally being done, that's it, that's
not enough to do r of course, but it's being
done, it's already being done,
so here's a judicial file to cease
or simply an archived file,
it's a document that has  was produced at a
specific moment which has its own history and
which ultimately comes to life also through our
own questions I always come back
to this question of the question
because I think it is
essential
of course there are things that are
given in an archive the archipelago is
dated
it contains names it
possibly contains a place
it contains for example a
description of the facts it happened
was levente the event at the camp in the
military  of the soldier is challenged
by what he is accused of etc. but
despite everything beyond that what
the archiving can deliver is
obviously the questions we have unfortunately
it is not only the historians who
come with questions towards  the
documents but they are also the
citizens since the archive is
part of a democratic
state system and to which everyone must be
able to have access for
various reasons research is
one of the questions
of genealogical questions are of it
others fault property issues
there is a whole series of
questions and reasons rather that
can lead a person to want to
consult an archive
i had
two other questions  ns I don't know if I
didn't also leave the game
maybe I started with a question
and I would agree on the other after the
first it
's as
an average citizen on wants we want
to tackle understanding a little  in
any case go and look in what
had been done what is in the
Belgian archives what are we
confronted with because to take up
what you were saying earlier an example
given earlier of the process
of  mastery of the half-breeds of
colonization in
the issue of the trial was had to be
offside it was access to archives
and is access to their
administrative documents and therefore the difficulty has
in any case for finally for all and  to
all these children who are now
adults to have access to
understand what awaits and therefore
even having a battery in fact two
in their case from to legal expert
who prayed with them so
felt like it  was the cross and the
banner
now
in what state  t are only now
if a lambda citizen can also
attack what here are the obstacles in
fact
then the obstacles to accessing the
archives they can be multiple
indeed so of course we can
speak of the ideal of the opening of the
archives but  then there is the concrete and
the difficulties to access it just a
point before answering that on the oriented
in general all the archives that they
are produced therefore by by by the state
where they are private or by
individuals  they always have a deadline
are barely a legal opening deadline
to say that we consider that after x
years an archive becomes public
often this deadline is 30 years for
everything concerning, for example, which is produced
by the  state of course to this
thirty-year period applies
as many exceptions related to the question
of privacy related to the question of
the classification of documents all that
is important to answer the
specific question if we pre  nd the
judicial archives
its 100 years it is said that after a hundred
years a judicial archive is
public so do we say to ourselves oh
there but then there we have access to nothing at
all of course that if there is also
exceptions in the other direction, that is to
say derogations of access and that is
typically what
researchers do to have access to
documents is that they must therefore
apply for authorization this
request it can be addressed to
the general archivist of the kingdom where it
can for example for the case once
again of certain judicial archives
be addressed to the college of prosecutors
therefore for example on a previous project
to be able to access documents which
had less  hundred years and which
dealt with war crimes trials
in Belgium I had to make a request to the
college of public prosecutors
saying but here it is for research reasons
with this is the objective I
would like to access such and such
doc  ument so it's a process that
takes some time and we're giving you
access now what's the problem
more specifically with with
African archives is that so as
we said it's archives that have
already traveled in part or  that they
were in quotes repatriated in 1960
and then they had a
rather turbulent history of conservation which
was accompanied by a history of I will
say opacity all the same quite quite
marked they were in
fact considered these archives while  like the
archives of the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs and the archives of defense
like archives in quotation marks
called sensitive which could
possibly present a certain
danger if we focused if we accessed them
for order in the Seine in
society etc.  speeches
obviously
finally I think put everything in
quotes but here it is and therefore that
means that for a very long time his
archives in fact they were quite
closed  including research but most
certainly to a lay citizen
as you said a moment ago
one of the obstacles
to the opening of its archives
even from a fair point of view of the
researcher without yet entering into the
question of mobilization by
civil society or by individuals
it was that we lacked instruments
lacked instruments to know what
existed where it was what is the
scope of the documents
what did it contain in short what
we call an inventory an
inventory or a database that
would make it possible to locate, target and
therefore then request access to such and such a
document to answer such
and such a question Obviously there the
problem arises in exactly the same
way for  individuals who
would like to access these documents is
therefore today we are in a
quite different phase and here I
refer to the work of my colleagues and
to the mettis project and to the
general archives of the roya  ume who have also
released a guide to the
so-called
colonial African archives in Belgium which is a guide
which I think is two thousand pages long
and which is finally accessible in
open access on the internet so the donation
I can provide the link  is therefore who
explains one all these steps who says
that now what is happening
is that all these archives which were
kept at the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs which was filtering so he is the one
who uses the word years but my
archivist colleagues a little  the head of the
client in quotation marks the documents to
which access was given today
these documents are being
repatriated to the state archives and this
repatriation to the state archives
clearly marks a break
with the past in the sense  where
the state archives their mission their
first mission is to make
documents
accessible and to make documents accessible and that means
putting archivists and researchers
on its  collections which are going to study them
which are going to map them which are going to
inventory them which are going to allow us to
give researchers public access to
these documents in a transparent way
because that is obviously indecent
it is ultimately equal access to the
archives  in
transparency so that does not
mean that when, as an individual or a
citizen, you have a question in relation to your
family, for example, you can
contact the archives and they will take
out a file from the shelf which will
give all  the answers obviously
when we come with our questions about our
past we will be confronted with
a whole series of potential sources
which will perhaps provide elements
or perhaps even only provide
clues and so that's it, that's it  one of the
difficulties obviously and the
archivists are there to support
researchers and citizens in this
quest but so it is true that this trial
but teese which stems from the re
Métis solution which was adopted by the House of
Representatives, of which it is nevertheless a
political decision at a time to say
there is a problem here of opening the
archives and this
problem must be remedied these archives must be
de facto
accessible  so this debate on
the opening of the archives we find
elsewhere I mean we can look at
what is happening in france in relation
to the archives / on the relations between
france and rwanda it is exactly the
same issues of openness
and d  ' egalitarian access I would say to its
archives whereas for the moment we are
still in something quite opaque on
one side and on the French side
I find what you are saying interesting
because in fact it is
done with this question of
fan access  in fact yes is not is not
is not is not only
a technical question it is above all a
political question and
is therefore to speak of access to equality
finally what this term is enough  speaking
the way you
're there reflects this
phase and its obstacles and the and
can it constitute as here is a
constraint in order to be able to understand
what what has in its archives
I actually had a small question in
relation to that I admit asked is what
the is what  the
is that the fact that it is these
archives have remained for a long time
finally I don't know if I can I don't know
if we can use the term cache and
manta is accessible
to allows to explain in fact is what
it is  a link with the
end explains part of the way in
which belgium managed its colonial past
and by that I mean the fact that there are
I think there are not many
flaws here there are  has not many
breasts of contribution history
educate woman who taught in the east
in the schools it's really very
recent so is
there a link between this inaccessibility
and the fact that it  it remained
a hidden story for a long time, well in
any case step by
step or
really close  ent in society
yes it is certain I come back to this
triptych justice history memory which
ultimately reflects a little zealously the
different aspects which come into
account in this question, that is to
say politics society in general
justice in the sense  can reparations be requested in
certain cases,
as is
the case in the trial, including the Métis trial,
but we know of other debates
in other formerly
colonized areas where this question can
arise, we think of  slaved etc finally
here we are
talking
about absent allaoui whose idea I take up again
it is not very clear so we have this
triptych and in this triptych I think
that there is also
not only memory but there is
also indeed research which
already exist to say that since 1960 there has
been no research obviously it
would be it would still be quite
unfair to all the
historians anthropologists to
political scientists who have worked on  these
questions now the question
is how does this research
obviously in quotation marks percolate
in society how they are received
how they are financed supported and
there the politician intervenes
obviously now what we
often see all the same finally me this  that
I observe because it is a question
that interests me in all that is
commission on the past once again
in very very diverse contexts and
that sometimes the politician comes to
place orders if we want
to look into  on questions which in fact
have already been dealt with by researchers,
but it is true that these commissions are
important because they make it possible to
put the spotlight on these questions
and to effectively open up the debate
in society and in education c  is
typically one of the most
important channels obviously to deal with to
deal with these issues from school so
I think that after I think the
situation  s are very different from one
school to another like now there
are things that are indeed moving
but it is certainly a whole the fact
that the archives then were not
hidden end it was possible to have
access to them but  it is true that it is
once again for the reasons that we have already
described it was very complicated
it was not exactly an
opening signal to say let's talk about
happening we are really very
interested politically in
mondy coming to touch with the past so
yes clearly it's part of this
set don't have silence but in
any case I would say
2.6 durance a bit variable geometry
or spaces more or less more or
less obscured but still  once
they have been worked on by
historians for decades already
another small question you are talking about
archi beaten to talk about the archives which
are which are in rwanda burundi rdc
finally archives
end of the colonial era so what is
what has in its  archives are there
any 1 what do we have to what
extent
they are they can be mobilized
so yes I think his motive there
are big big differences think
between between the different collections
so there personally I don't  I haven't
worked on these archives from that
time in these three countries
on site, I mean so I
can't say exactly
about their content either because I don't have
personal experience of that  but
therefore there is a series to keep it archived
which therefore were produced during the
colonial period
local archives produced by
local authorities I know that there are still
low archives in particular on the
question of public force if we
take the congo and  the drc therefore which is the
colonial army therefore a series of
files which are kept on the spot
of my two colleagues on the
current project on which I work
return from a mission there and therefore
have been able to see  its collections in
burundi also we have a series of
documents which are in the
national archives so these three countries of course have
national archives institutions
which are experiencing a lot of
financial material difficulties which
have also suffered
from the crises of the conflicts of the wars in
recent recent years  decades but
so there are documents which
are not extremely numerous I think
but there are indeed documents
in these 3
in these three centers produced at
different levels and there are all the
archives of the religious congregations
so there too for example  for
rwanda there we can think of cap d'ail
the bishopric where there are there there are
documents which date which date from this
period so we really have
national archives and
decentralized archives in these countries which
breaks the image of there are no documents a bit
because we still often say that in the
end to make history so
to resume  quite
generally from africa yes but we do
n't have any documents it's that the testimony
is totally false obviously there are a
lot of documents that exist
that existed unfortunately sometimes have
disappeared and so here we can
really break this idea who has not who has
no documents if we take the example
of rwanda obviously in 94 there is a
very great loss of a very large number
of documents which
then date perhaps more from the post-
colonial period but  I think including from the
colonial period who suffered
who suffered from destruction
displacement theft looting and c1
I'm going I asked a very last
question that holds a bit
it's not the simplest the most
the most  more comfortable
in fact when I feel like when we
're stupid we're sure it's finally that we're
in these debates on on on
questions of memory and that we
realize how finally it's a
feeling  that I had the impression that
I e  ue when when I was a child I
attended the trial cited to the processes
of women and is it is to see
how in fact what it is
finally historians and archives
in this context the tooth finally round a
central role 1 it's extremely
central time to allow access
only to be able to tell what's
inside so there's a role a bit of
gatekeepers
[Music]
no gatekeeper wii some
purposes to allow the  access to certain
memories to certain realities that
many people are unaware of so there is an
extremely finally role that
we want water that is very
political
that is a first element a second
element
which we finally talked about is  see
how much
in fact everyone needed as you said the
[Music]
the content of the archives is a point
of view of the nose at a given moment in a
given context and helped the no longer
here in a colonial context with
all the  symmetry to buy a con
there is no so suddenly I have the  impression
that from the point of view of people who is who
and who
are finally
kiki
who are mobilizing
for sure it is in any case on these
questions there we are
we must rely on
[Music]
finally that I do the same I think  in
time but I make the same analogy with
the law I have the impression that we
need the law but at the same time it's
not what it's not the tiki that
simplifies our lives
and therefore suddenly we  needs days and
if its political role but there is a whole
legislative apparatus which has which in
fact allows which allows to justify team
which gives a certain point of view of the
violence of colonization so
suddenly as in c1 as an agreement as
what a historian you are in there
because there is something about hockey
there is a
political role but at the same time
people are finally a lot of historians
that saying well in fact we have
we
will do what is also true  of we are going to
have a not neutral position of the two
to work on  documents on
which we try to bring out a
neutral message but lens fears there is
nothing that had 30 rue but in this
story so suddenly it was a bit to
the question a bit disjointed but I
think you see  what you want to do you see
what I mean this kind of
positioning in a debate which is
fortunately extremely apolitical but
where
seven
is this presence of history
both a guarantee finally a necessity
but at the same time  times a danger I
also think for both for you
but also for the people who cover
yes the question is is that
I am needed or
[Laughs]
no the request has certainly not
no individually  that's for sure but
no but I think it's a very
important question because then it's true
that I don't call it political
we can call it engaged we can see
there but it's a fundamental question
because that  It's been a
while since historians  s are no longer
fine most anyway are no longer
in the positivist idea of objectivity and neutral
ty and complet
and it is histo
y like all other disciplines
in the humanities and social scie
ces integrated
he fact that our point of view  given
our analysis it is built in
a given context we live in our
time so we are not I say we I
would not like to speak on behalf of all the
super young people I am not disconnected
from realities and moreover these
realities tell me  I'm interested in it
feed me on a daily basis and therefore
somewhere what is called the social demand
for history or memory these two
different things but which we see a lot
in societies today I think
that in fact it is fundamental to
on the one hand I would say me I need
as a researcher I speak for me me
I need as a researcher to
feel free from the choices and the questions
I ask so don't give not to have
the  impression that we  imposes on me ray a
research agenda while being
completely going costs to help guide
open up avenues think about
questions so that's a question that
I think it's something very
important it's this freedom  to
look for her obviously fundamental
but on the other hand to counterbalance
this tried to answer all the
elements that you have conducted
this research that I will conduct to
take an example but I mean in
an abstract way she also needs
this  social demand that is to say that
if there is no interest if
nobody cares
if there is no public funding if
or even private foundations but that's
if there is no  there is no impetus behind
this research is that this
research cannot also produce
something for society so it is
useless because what is asked of us
is still also useful to publish
in scientific journals  etc
but it is still also to contribute  to the
debate of contributing to knowledge
is in any case I would say in all
humility, that is to say that by being
aware of the limits of our own
work because this limit it can
be the same thing it can be the languages
e master a  maybe the
possibilities we had to go and
consult documents it could be
yes even the interpretation that we make of
certain things but which all the same
brings something and therefore the story
is not something fixed I  think
that this is also important to
point out and it is all the more true
in subjects like these which
are treated by
different authorities justice
civil society
historians teaching not
only teaching at the  he school but also
at university is also a real
question for
me so
it is extremely important that all of this
is still connected but without
losing this freedom without losing one's
freedom because I think that
then there we  will come to the question of
the expert,
that is to say a historian or a
sociologist jurist who is called upon in a
trial to shed light on
the past or on a social question, that
obviously exists, we have plenty
of examples in the  history full of
trials and it is especially the trials
for crimes against humanity for
war crimes for crimes of
genocide in which we observe all
that there it is still a role a
different role but but but here it is  we are
talking about research for me
research must be part of
this society but
I would say not by seeking this
neutrality but on the other hand by seeking
how to say a subjectivity
which is necessarily there because the
questions we ask are
necessarily  dictated by a lot of things
the discussion we are having today
will no doubt at one time or another
guide a question that I will
ask myself in a research so it is
great somewhere because  and it's
obviously a dialogue but so that
's something subjective
obviously just the way we
answer this question
it must be based on pascal must
be I think it should be based
on all these elements that we talked about at the
beginning of the interview, that is to say the
criticism of the sources
the fact of
how to say not to come with
preconceived ideas in relation to the
resources not to seek this
answer there whatever it is or to
reinforce this thesis but  to be open
to elements which perhaps would come to
contradict this thesis basically I would say to
respect the ways that we find in
the archives or the people that
we see when we do oral history we will
say it is  a bit of ethics I do
n't know about research ethics I
think that's what is fundamental
and there all the tools of the researcher
allow precisely to answer this
question these questions may be
subjective but which are  framed pe  nser
through these tools which are those and
so I believe that this is where
the political borders are drawn a little
history memory without
these borders being obviously obviously prevents
dialogue beyond its
borders that is very important  but
and then everyone defines of course for
themselves
what role they take on and in what role
they want to play and of course
I don't know if that answers because
listen it's great in any case I
think our chips that fatou to all  the
elements that we discussed there we can
put them even more in debate
with the when you come to make his
presentation with the indies and that the
members of kakobola have so thank you
and the reverend
and so suddenly we see each other  in a
few weeks
thank you very much